[MUSIC]
It was June 23rd, 2018, and I was visiting
the tree refugee camp in Georgia.
And there's a tree camp is an interesting
sight to see because across the horizon
there in the middle eastern desert, where
ancient civilizations once lived It is
a makeshift settlement of row after row
after row of corrugated metal trailer.
And this is where
the folks is actually live,
often they have paintings on the side
drawn by children in the camp.
And on that day I was visiting with
a colleague of mine who works for
Save the Children Jordan and we got
to meet a friend of mine named Esma.
We visited Esma trailer, and
we knocked on the wooden door and
Esma kindly greeted us as she always,
does with such great kindness,
and we walk in and we sit on the dark
brown carpet on a dark brown cushion with
the blue flowers all around the trailer.
And we sit and
we drink tea together shy in Arabic,
the shy that she had prepared for us.
And as we were drinking our tea Esma was
talking to us about her life in the camper
life back in Syria and
the great work she's doing in
the camp suddenly there was
a loud noise around us and so
the trailer walls started rumbling
it felt like the ground was shaking.
And finally I looked over
to my colleagues looked
over to Esma says something going on,
and I said, Yes, just wait.
And in that moment, 10 children burst
through that wooden door we had come
through onto the ground and the carpet and
the brown carpet in front of us, and
rolled around and played with one another,
and the room had become chaos.
And just a few seconds later, they each
stand up, give asthma a big hug and
greet her.
Esma says hello to each of them by
name [FOREIGN] A greeting in Arabic.
[FOREIGN] She says it to each of them and
then finally they sit down in
a semicircle around Esma and
Esma sits with them And she grabs a hold
of a children's book that was there.
And suddenly after grabbing her baby
boy Muhammad who had been crawling all
over the carpet, putting him firmly
in her lap, she begins the story.
And it's as if, like that magical
ambiance had taken over the trailer.
All the kids are so focused in,
their locked in they're listening to
everything Esma has to say as she reads
the pages of the book and the dialogue.
She reads with her voice moving up and
down,
like that of an actress to make
sure the kids are engaged.
And this book in particular is one
about a Syrian boy who In his words,
wants to be a pilot of love,
not a pilot of war.
So this goes on for some time
Esma reads a page of the book and
then she pivots the book so
that she can show it to everybody.
All the kids the illustrations in
the book and the kids lean in and they're
eager their eyes wide to see what was on
the page that Asma had just describe.
And finally after about 5,
10 minutes of reading Esma closes
the book suddenly it says [FOREIGN]
Which means the end in Arabic.
The magical ambiance is gone, and the kids
are going back to their raucous behaviors.
They're playing with one another.
They're hanging out and they head out the
door eventually but not before they give
Esma one more big hug, one more grieving
to let her know how much they love her.
Esma is a poet, author, entrepreneur and
story teller in the Zaatari
refugee camp in Jordan but
it took a lot for her to get there.
Esma grew up in the town of Daraa,
Syria, where she lived
her life of relative peace and
stability with her family.
That ended in 2012 when the Syrian war
began and when her house was burned to
the ground along with all of her
belongings, including the journals that
she had written her whole life's
memories and stories about.
And then she crossed the desert to
go to the Zaatari camp in Jordan and
within two years of her time in the camp,
came the darkest moment of her life
which is the miscarriage of her child,
due largely to a lack of
readily accessible health care.
It was in the middle of this darkness
the darkest moment of her life that
Esma found the spark within her.
The spark being these children's
storytelling initiative that I described
Esma wanted to make sure that not
a single child in the Zaatari camp,
not one child,
felt as though they did not have a future.
These children who had dealt with words
like war, violence, bombing shelling's for
too long, and who'd grown up knowing
very little other than the Zaatari
camp would have hoped for a future,
would have the ability to dream and
would feel confident and
empowered and who they are.
And that's why Esma started the
storytelling initiative that now brings
dozens and dozens of children to
a trailer each month or each week.
Esma is one of the most inspiring
people I have ever met in my life.
But when we hear the stories
of refugees in the media and
from the mouths of many politicians,
we don't hear Esma story.
We tend to hear the stories of victims or
villains to binary stories either
we hear the story of victims.
People who are looked down upon
should be looked down upon.
Why because they don't have agency
because they're pitiful human
beings who need to be given a handout or
we're told the story of violence.
Why do we look down upon refugees because
they're criminals, they're going to take
our jobs, and they're going to ruin our
country's cultures if they're welcomed in.
Either way,
we're told to look down at refugees.
In reality, refugees could not be further
from these tropes that I just described.
And these refugees are powerful,
creative, inspiring people,
some of the most resilient,
innovative human beings on the planet.
Refugees contribute economically.
The US government found that in
the ten years ending in 2014,
the net fiscal impact of refugees on the
American economy was about $63 billion.
That's above and beyond the investment
it takes the small investment,
but mighty investment it takes to
bring refugees into the country.
A small investment that
would pay dividends but
one that has not done enough,
especially as resettlement centers have
been decimated over the last few years.
Refugees are some of the most
entrepreneurial people on earth and
the most extreme entrepreneurs.
They're 1.5 to 2x more entrepreneurial
than native born citizens in the US.
And they create jobs, millions of jobs for
people around the world in their new
adopted countries and
in camps like century.
Beyond economics, socially refugees
are there for most difficult times?
So when Hurricane Harvey hit Houston
it was the Afghan Cultural Centre, and
many others of course that was providing
aid to firemen, firefighters, firemen and
women who were helping ensure that
people were protected and safe and
provided with food and
water and what they needed.
In Utica, when Utica,
New York when there were factory closures
across the rust belt and when a town
that was once fast growing was dwindling
and populations people abandoned.
It was refugees from 40 countries
that rekindled the spirit
there that repopulated churches and
mosques that brought hope to
a city that was declining rapidly and
is now stabilized.
And most recently during this pandemic
refugees have provided food for
the elderly,
changing their small businesses and
into opportunities to serve folks
who are most disadvantaged during
the pandemic providing food and
equipment that's necessary.
But more importantly than what refugees
contribute is who refugees are.
Equal human beings with dignity that
deserve to be treated with respect
just like all of us, as one poet says,
no one chooses refugee camps.
They didn't choose their situations and
it could have happened to any of us.
They're equal human beings
who deserve respect,
independent of their contributions.
And I believe we all deep
down know that refugees and
all of the people different than us are
equal human beings who deserve respect.
But there's a disconnect, because when
polled the majority of Americans have
said in the past that they do not want to
welcome Syrian refugees to this country at
all, or they only want to welcome Syrians
from certain religions backgrounds.
And in some ways this disconnect
actually is intuitive.
It's very sad but it's intuitive because
in the absence of knowing a Syrian or
knowing a refugee or knowing someone in
any group that is different than us we
have to fill in the gaps.
And where do we fill in the gaps.
We fill in the gaps from the cacophony
of sounds and media clips and
politician speeches and headlines and
politicize things that are all
over the media that tell us the victim or
the villain narrative.
Not the narrative that says these
are beautiful human beings,
with lives of dignity that are being
played out in communities.
We don't hear the story of Esma.
We don't hear the story of Utica.
We don't hit a story of
Houston after Harvey.
My hope is for three things.
Most urgently, my hope is that
the world takes its duty committed to
after World War II and
welcomes refugees into their countries.
There are 27 million refugees in the world
right now a number that has gone up over
the last week as half a million Ukrainians
have huddled together and train stations
to exile out of their country because of
the horrendous violence that's occurring
in Ukraine My hope is that
countries band together and
commit to welcoming refugees because
right now we are failing miserably.
Only a shocking 0.2% of refugees in
the world are resettled because nations
are failing to accommodate and to welcome
them Beyond that, my hope is that there
are more stories that allow us to look
past the victim or villain narratives more
authentic human stories that bring the
voices of people like Esma into our lives.
My book that's coming out in May 25
million Sparks is meant to tell the untold
story of refugee entrepreneurs including
Esma and I hope it contributes to that.
But beyond the stories,
I have a greater hope.
And that hope is that each of us when
we're faced with these stories and
narratives about who refugees are or
who people of different races or
ethnicities or religions than us are,
we stop and we look within.
And we remember that yes
everyone is equal to us and
that their differences should
be honored and respected and
then everyone deserves to be treated with
dignity just the way Esma treats those
wonderful children in her trailer during
her storytelling initiatives in the camp.
And then everyone, everyone is a powerful,
beautiful, creative human being
who deserves to be treated with
equal respect and love, thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]